hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear all right um I
noticed something else getting back to
you that it said that I could dial this
number into the dialpad so 5 3 4 2 1 4 5
4 3 2 1 foot help maybe if I had my
phone
port nope nothing happening ah I don't
know maybe from in gear 1 4
nope I don't know I I have no idea what
it was a talk I'm just gonna move on
oh there's a keypad 5 or 3 2 1 or no
oh darn it someone supposed to know that
am I supposed to call the number and
then I get
okay that's something about dialing into
the numpad so oh no try to find my
dripped magazine article very cool to be
an article about depression so familiar
call that know how do I know oh just
wasted a bullet phone screen can be
accessed by selecting the user ah oh I
like use you I want to call at one bar
ah boy three to four okay
punch punch with my fist oh man I'm
getting stuck on the simplest of public
in all right
making a sham of myself work my number
oh no I don't know all big mystery to me
what do I know I'm gonna hit it a lot
seriously come on
I'm at a loss um
but I'm actually this day is to keep
from embarrassing myself I'm gonna cut
it and I'm gonna come back when I cook
it so is it staring me in the face so
I'm not gonna waste because by jumping
around and doing it I'll be back in a
bit
hello everybody I'm back okay I was just
mashing buttons here and I found out
it's busy button idiot five four three
two one
I got a punch of it five four three two
one four dile dile okay
there we go finally
No I'm depressed
okay
I need help please okay
Tammi helped me five two four seven that
was help
nothing's it up baby more help to you
also double your onaconda stick ha ha Oh
wacky way 5 2 2004 I wasn't paying
attention for the five two four seven
okay okay we're good
bingo hang on I guess dick like a 1/4 of
a chair who's that
Gary ladies good girls
terrified of you all know I'm not so
manly who's out there who's over there
he's dark dark what is this place like a
maze whoo I don't like it that's a wall
that's just walls what the heck
there was no point in coming up here
sigh trapping me okay I didn't try okay
all right let's see what you got ha what
the hooter okay okay screw this
stick I'm getting the gun oh no I'm
almost out of bullets
oh no I get up here nope ah ah no no no
no no no whoo where does that chainsaw
guy the saw were what the hell where was
he
oh don't like not like a Gurkha out of
here nope no no I refuse
oh not a ladder not gonna get me Bobby
saw man
get out of here spooky spooky me up
starting right off with a drip drop
don't be dripping don't be drop it drop
it to pigs me know like you know like
long set of bullets
Oh me definitely do not like this deck
stick 600
did something come out of your mouth
where's my litem all right so we can hit
it off
oh it was on ha
get out of here nope miss me Oh your
tongue can't touch me can't lick this
fit I broke you free what the hell is
wrong with me are you bro free I broke
you free I don't know honey let's get
matter no no no no no funky strong water
[ __ ] rock it to them ah
get get get get the gun gun time for gun
headshot
no no terrible oh come on
I see the blood spatter boom I got one
bullet left
great
I guess not
[ __ ] too fast for you come for that I
gotta shoot me up with some morphine
Oh use it up I just gosh Oh get you
hey why start cut on his wrist just
supposed to signify something I saw
there was like a little scar on his
wrist this guy's really dead he's in
dead land like Alice in Wonderland I
don't look it
so strong is this the real world of
giant fries
what the heck no this is no way the real
world oh what is that oh I don't like
this oh boy I do not like stupid monkey
crap out of you I want to I wanted this
doesn't do as much damage as the knife
it doesn't seem to like the knife is
more of a cutting weapon anyway so I
don't know I don't know no oh super done
in your tongue can't touch this knife is
not as
okay guys it's not as strong knife is
nuts
those guys are just tough oh man he
whacked me up all right no no I don't
even need God [ __ ] womp wrong all right
enough of that huh what's here oh my
golly I don't even know what I'm doing
anymore all right but whatever I'm doing
it's gonna have to wait so thank you
guys so much for watching and I will see
you in the next part
bye bye